welcome back to coffee with kennel and
our series on how youtube works this
series
is going to help you understand youtube
so that you can get
more views grow your subscribers and
make money
on youtube and this is a very practical
series you know youtube
recently released an article and
a detailed breakdown of how their
products
work including youtube search including
youtube recommended videos and so you
know there's a lot of
youtube experts so called out there in
the world with a lot of opinions and i
certainly share my opinions as well but
here's the deal this information is
straight from the source
straight from youtube themselves and
we're going to be breaking it down and
looking at
it in detail so you can get an edge on
youtube
by really understanding what it takes to
rank your videos in search how youtube
search works
and how you can get massive views in the
process and here's the cool thing
65 of people use youtube to help them
solve
a problem so tell me in the comments
what problem do you
solve with your youtube channel um and
what
problem does your videos solve you know
there's two main categories on youtube
you can either be in entertainment or
education and at think media and think
marketing
we really help people that are educators
that want to help people solve problems
but even
entertainers solve the problem of board
and boredom they solve the problem of
of uh people needing an escape so tell
me in the comments what problem do you
solve
but this shows us that youtube again is
the second largest search engine in the
world and 65 percent of people use
youtube to help them solve a problem so
if you're fired up for today's coffee
with cannell
hit the like button let me know what
problem your channel solves
and we're going to be talking about how
youtube search works
and for tips for hacking the youtube
algorithm
we're going to bust some myths that a
lot of youtube experts spread
even though youtube themselves
contradict those myths
we're going to talk about tips for how
you can hack the youtube algorithm and
get more views and subscribers
and we're also going to talk about what
channel authority is and why it matters
and today's episode is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com
this is our one hour class that we've
created here at think media to actually
go in depth it's an hour long
to show you how to leverage youtube
search and suggested videos hack the
algorithm
and really build a high impact and high
profit channel
and it's been updated for 2021 and so if
you have not registered for that yet
thinkmasterclass.com link in the
description below
and do not miss out on that here
are some screenshots and all of the
information this video is taken directly
from a youtube article and this is a
screenshot that says
with over 500 hours of content uploaded
to youtube every minute
take a breath 500 hours
uploaded every minute right finding what
you need
would be nearly impossible without some
help sorting through all the videos so
this is youtube in this video
youtube explains to us how their search
function
works and this becomes really important
because if you're going to stand out in
the sea of noise
on youtube you have to understand these
principles
because don't worry about the volume of
content or the volume of competition
find a way to be a meaningful specific
in a world of wandering generalities you
got to find a way
to really carve out your niche and make
sure you're making specific videos that
are answering specific questions
and leveraging these tips and tools and
here's a quick story that illustrates
this this is nolan molt
from the think media team he's one of
the content creators on our think media
channel
a cinematographer has worked on tv shows
in la
and um really a camera expert and he's
really been getting
into grilling with his wife madeline uh
in la
and they've been grilling up all kinds
of different stuff different meats
different vegetables
and so he was going to youtube to look
for information
for something to grill and he looked for
how to barbecue
kabobs okay and so when we talk about
youtube search
and what is a ranked video well rank
video is a video that shows up
in the top results of youtube
search and the top result for that
search term was this video called kebabs
on the grill
simple and easy and i don't know if you
can see it but you can see which channel
it's from
it is by sean cannell right this is
actually
this video is from my personal channel
and this video came
out 12 years ago so all of a sudden
nolan is trying to figure out how to
how to barbecue kebabs on the grill and
he at first doesn't even recognize this
as me because it looks like i just got
hit by a truck in the opening of that
video as you can see on my face there
uh but i was on vacation with my wife
sonia i got up from a nap and i was like
let's make a video because we're gonna
cook these kebabs but i did some
strategic things to this video and
years later over 448 000 views later
nolan stumbles over the video completely
on his own it was like oh my gosh
like the stuff that we talk about
whether that's in our advanced trainings
like video ranking academy or whatever
he's like dude sean's like been doing
this man like what the heck now he's
teaching me how to
grow kebabs which in these days i was
testing
these strategies and these things but
here's the deal youtube's always
constantly updating and now youtube is
telling us exactly how they rank videos
but here's the power of it and this is
what you want to master because what
would it be worth to you to get a video
that has 448 thousand views
what would it be worth to you to get a
video that's being viewed eight years
after you create it eight years
after you create it this is why
youtube's the best social network on the
planet period
because it's leveraged you create a
piece of content once if you do it right
if you position yourself in the right
niche with the right strategy
and that video can get views subscribers
grow your business
generate income help you create freedom
for your family
for weeks months and even years to come
over eight years is even possible
and this is just one super random
example that just happened recently
and here's what's crazy is by mastering
youtube search
um it's changed my life mastering
youtube search has changed my life
i've grown multiple youtube channels to
over 2 million subscribers combined
another one's about to go over
a hundred thousand um subscribers for
another silver play button and it's not
just
changing my life it's actually changed
multiple of our students lives
um who've even started from scratch
literally from zero
and grown past 100 000 subscribers many
people have created part-time and
full-time incomes
all from the power of what we're
learning in this video so here's the
question
where do youtube views come from right
where do youtube views
come from there's a lot of different
places but there's a few main sources
and when we look at think media in 2019
youtube search was responsible for 43
of the traffic that means the views on
the channel
think media got around 20 million views
in 2019
and that means around 10 million from
search now we have to acknowledge
that different channels and different
niches and different industries
have different places where their
traffic comes from
think media is a utility channel it is
an education channel it helps people
solve a problem and again
if you had to choose between
entertainment and education i would
choose education nine times out of ten
entertainment you're a musician you're a
comedian even you're kind of a vlogger
although if you do it right you can
apply these strategies you're trying to
entertain people it's kind of a
different conversation and there's maybe
even other people to watch
in terms of trying to figure out how to
grow those types of channels
i also think that it's very difficult
it's kind of like trying to get an
acting job in hollywood like there's a
lot of competition
but when you go into education search
based content utility based channels
i actually believe it's not just easier
it's practical to build a five six
figure income
to build up your channel because it is
actually solving a specific problem and
youtube
is very much an entertainment platform
but it's also an education platform and
with the
pandemic and the lockdown and everything
massive people are thinking about
youtube in terms
of education and so this kind of proves
and shows
how much i mean 10 million views in 2019
on think media came
from creating search based content not
only that
but over a million views
1.1 million views came from google
search
now i don't have a good website i don't
have a legit blog i'm not good at
uh wordpress seo i don't even have a
wordpress site
um i've just got a random website that's
been updated three and a half years ago
or something like that
but youtube is our main traffic source
home base traffic driver
of course email list and of course
website for practical things
but youtube is the main place just
creating youtube videos
1.1 million views have been earned
from think media from google search
because never forget
google owns youtube right
so um very very powerful and so here are
the four
factors that are outlined from youtube
themselves straight from the source
that influence youtube search here's how
they determine it number one is
relevance number two is engagement
number three is quality
and number four is search and watch
history we're gonna explain all four
i'll repeat all four and i'll give you
tips on each one number one is relevance
number two is engagement
number three is quality number four is
search and wasps watch history
and we're gonna be looking through the
exact quotes
from youtube themselves so hit like if
you're getting value so far number one
relevance and i quote to estimate
relevance we look into many factors
such as how well the title tags
description and video content match
your youtube search query
end quote all right so the first
factor to determine if your videos are
going to rank
and here's what's interesting this
article is actually
speaking more to the viewer they're
telling the viewer how youtube works
but you and i the creator can learn so
much
from this article and i've linked it up
in the description uh below by the way
so let's break this down to estimate
relevance so
youtube wants your video to be relevant
to a person that's looking for something
the way they determine that
is the title so you gotta master titles
interestingly enough is the tags said
straight from the horse's mouth now
there's some people who say tags don't
matter and youtube has also said
they don't matter nearly as much as they
did tags are not going to change your
life or change your videos life
but some people say they don't matter at
all if youtube tells me they matter
then i'm going to pay attention and they
obviously matter description
the words you put in your youtube
description the content you put
in the description of your youtube video
it matters but most of all
the video content itself see what we
call
title and tags and description all that
stuff we call it metadata
it's the metadata around your video and
even though youtube now can like
literally watch your video and it like
sees there's a man's face a woman's face
there's like nature there's a bird
it sees a lot of things just in creating
the video content itself
the words and the metadata that you put
around your video
matters so that youtube has
a starting point of whether or not your
video should show up in search or what
your video is about
now i would say that based on my
experience again it is the content
yourself that matters most
but here's something that maybe some
wouldn't notice the key here
is then match your search query so if
you want to rank your videos
it's not just like getting your title
your tags right like the actual topic
itself
or how relevant it is to the person
that's searching for it really matters
therefore what i mean how you architect
your content needs to be in congruence
in
alignment with what someone's actually
looking for therefore
if someone comes to youtube with a
problem and
they're what kind of words are they
using what kind of words are they typing
in
what kind of content are they looking
for
if you basically serve up content that
is cooked
to perfection for what it is they're
looking for or as close as
possible then that viewer satisfaction
will be there
and you can get your video to show up in
the search query and keep showing up
there all right
a lot of fancy words this is a deep
episode let me know if you've been
getting value so far
by gently touching the like button and
telling me well that hurt my head
and we're gonna go deeper like this is
some this is a deep strategy session but
here we go
here's the takeaways number one master
metadata this takes time to learn
make a commitment to learning how to
master metadata on youtube number two
content is king
that's forever true on social media the
internet content is king like the
content in your video really matters
cream always rises to the top no matter
how many cups of coffee you pour
you have to have great content when it
comes to
your videos but here's another one that
i think people miss
the to the degree that you understand
the viewer
you will win or lose on youtube here's
how i'd another way to put it the
creators who understand the viewer the
best
win yeah the creators who understand the
viewer the best
win let me throw a word at you
psychology
mindset if you understand how the viewer
the searcher is
thinking and you architect content for
them
using the words they use you're going to
win or lose
based on the degrees with which you
understand the viewer
i would argue that if you go oh that's
that's easy i totally understand the
viewer i don't think i do
i think at arguably an advanced level
have built a big business 12 full-time
people on think media
you know multiple youtube channels we're
obsessed
with trying to understand the viewer
still and it's a lifelong process and
journey
you know in business a similar
perspective is it's the business that
understands the customer best wins
so you apply that to youtube you got to
understand and basically kind of get
inside of the mind of who the viewer is
and i've noticed a lot of people kind of
create selfish content they're sort of
just like
in their own bubble they're not thinking
about other people or understanding
other people
kind of just saying what they want to
say creating what they want to create
sort of just speaking what they want to
speak assuming
a lot of things and so to agree with you
with which you understand the viewer
you'll win and here's another big one
your choice of your youtube channel
topic
this cannot be understated the one of
the greatest levers you have for youtube
success
is actually choosing the right niche
so if you go well i just i don't get a
lot of views
well is anyone even looking for your
kind of content my videos just no one's
like really searching for them
then go and create something that people
are actually searching for you know
like you could create whatever you want
it's your tube right it's youtube
but your choice of actually choosing to
position yourself
in in a niche that is highly searched of
course
affects whether or not you win with
youtube search
well sean there's people there's big
creators that don't even like use tags
and use metadata
and they create like prank videos that's
a whole different strategy and that's
great
like study that out if that's your thing
but if you want to leverage
the topic of this video is youtube
search so if you want to leverage
youtube search
make sure you choose a highly searched
niche
okay let me know if you get value out of
this video so far that was just number
one this is what youtube is telling us
here's the second quote
engagement so the first thing they look
for is relevance and they defined
by the way just some of the signals like
they don't actually tell us
every single signal but the fact they
chose to list
titles tags description as well as how
well
you you know youtube's choice of words
and i definitely recommend reading the
article
the link in the description it helps us
understand obviously it's what they put
weight on number two
engagement engagement signals
are a valuable way to determine
relevance
we incorporate incorporate aggregate
engagement
signals from users i.e
we may look at the watch time of a
particular video
for a particular query to determine if
the video
is considered relevant to the query by
users
so it's talking about engagement signals
what's an engagement signal well
engagement signals are any any way the
viewer has
to engage with your video this could
include things like they can like the
video they can comment
on the video they could share the video
they can scrub on the video did you know
youtube knows if you touch a part or you
rewind a part that's real-time
interaction on the video
however the biggest engagement signals
are things like click through rate and
watch time or average view duration
because that is me engaging with it like
if i
walk into a grocery store and i spend
five minutes looking at the apples
touching the apples feeling the apples
and
expecting the apples besides the fact
that everyone watching me would be like
that's the weirdest dude ever why is he
spending so much time touching all the
apples and that's unsanita
unsanitary especially during a pandemic
or any time
but i would be engaging with the apples
i would be ignoring there's all kinds of
other produce in the produce section
but i'd be spending my time on the
content i would be touching the content
a click-through rate is engagement you
use your mouse to click
on a video or you use your finger to tap
on a video on your smartphone
you just engage with it okay wow that
person clicked on it
oh wow now they're spending a minute on
the video they're spending five minutes
on the video they're spending 10 minutes
on the video
so these are things that could be
considered engagement signals what are
the tips
lesser engagement signals are things
like likes and comments
they matter i am drifting into my
opinion to be clear here
and my experience but from what we can
see
in terms of youtube studio and analytics
and we'll cover that in future videos
strong engagement signals the two
biggest ones
are like audience retention and
click-through rate does the person click
on the video
do they go into the produce section and
actually touch the product
put it in their cart and buy it or do
they skip over it right
um and do they spend time like how long
do you keep the person watching
how many watch time minutes does the
video get so it's terms like audience
retention
average view duration and watch time
those are what really matters views of
course matter
but one view could be one second as
opposed to somebody spending an
hour long on your content so there's
different engagement signals
if you want your videos to show up in
the top of search you need people
engaging with your content
so you need to create good content you
have to see how do i increase audience
retention how do i increase watch time
how do i increase click through rate
good thumbnails
it kind of comes down to a lot of the
basics that we learn around youtube but
this is youtube saying how they decide
what shows up in youtube search number
three
finally for quality our systems
are designed to identify signals that
can help determine which channels
demonstrate
listen expertise authoritativeness
and trustworthiness on a given topic
this is major man
this is what we've been calling it think
media channel
authority okay and this is quote unquote
from
youtube themselves their systems
are looking for signals that help
demonstrate channels that demonstrate
expertise if you want to be the go-to
expert you want to have
expertise in a subject then youtube
is going to rank your content higher
authoritativeness
you're seen as an authority on something
and trustworthiness
how would they know well one
is when you build your content in a
particular niche for example
i'll give like at think media one of the
biggest topics we've become known for
is best camera for youtube anything to
do with camera for youtube
and as youtube observes
the algorithms observe that people click
on the video
that i create called best camera for
youtube they dwell on it they
watch it and whenever i release videos
in the future subscribers and
non-subscribers
really like best camera for youtube
videos they go okay
this channel maybe these other topics
aren't getting engaged with as much that
sean creates but whenever he talks about
best camera for youtube
people watch it their view of
satisfaction is high like they like it
um clearly there's an authoritativeness
there and even a trustworthiness
now without going too far down any
rabbit holes just because someone
watches an entire video doesn't mean
that they trust you
but one of the ways people could signify
trust of you
is that they spend time with you if you
listen to somebody and instantly you're
like dude this person's
just bs man like they don't even know
what they're talking about like
you're gonna bounce off the video but if
you dwell on the video it could
signify trustworthiness so the quality
of the content
but here's what i really want you to see
at the end of this quote from youtube it
says
on a given topic it's what's missed by
most people everybody out here want to
do it
wants to do a variety channel but
youtube wants and likes to categorize
people
and even stereotype people into a niche
to say man this channel has authority
expertise
and is trustworthy about a particular
topic so it's like my friend ben from
keto camp here's a great point
his channel is about ketosis about
health and
all about keto hence ketocamp right
if he creates a video and he has the
best title and tags and description
best camera for youtube and i create a
video
you know title tags description best
camera for youtube and let's assume
every single thing about the video is
the same i'm going to rank that video
much higher than him most likely almost
guaranteed
because youtube is categorizing me and
saying well think media has authority
expertise and trustworthiness in a
particular area because they've been
being consistent
they've been building up momentum around
a particular given topic
furthermore though ben is over here
talking about
keto having keto interviews with experts
authors being consistent at least two
videos a week
last couple years one of our vra
students silver play button
crushing it like building up his
influence
but it's in a particular topic so
therefore he can
almost he gets such he gets a head start
in that given topic because of his
expertise authority and all those things
that are built in that area
so the takeaways from number three
youtube telling us how youtube search
works
is that channel authority is real that
you can build up your channel authority
over time and it's important
because they're going to rank videos in
search based on
expertise authoritativeness
trustworthiness what we call channel
authority
secondly focus on a specific topic and
niche down
keto camp barbecue uh you know
cameras adobe premiere video editing
software
um you know makeup tips the more you
reach down
budget makeup tips you know drugstore
makeup
just the more you are in a particular
topic youtube wants to
and you can build up authority and
trustworthiness around that topic
and then finally on number three
consistency matters
and here's what i mean by that
consistency matters
people go oh yeah i just need to upload
a video every week shoot man
i fell off the horse how many videos
you've been uploading a week tell me in
the comments
how many videos you've been uploading a
week consistency
does not just mean upload videos on a
regular basis
because you might be old i'm not
uploading seven videos a week i'm
consistent i would challenge that
do you have a consistent message also
are you talking about a consistent
topic also do you have a consistent
brand
as well are you consistent
in terms of your value proposition
meaning the problem that you solve and
what people look to you for
so consistency is not just about
frequency it's actually about congruency
of your message your branding your
videos your topic
and when you dial that in it boosts your
channel authority
it boosts your expertise authority
authoritativeness and trustworthiness in
youtube in youtube's eyes
and now you're like dang i am
ranking videos i'm showing up in search
more
because of what youtube calls
quality quality so hit like if you've
been getting value if you've learned
anything in this video so far
we have the number fourth tip coming up
the question of the day though is what
specific topic does your channel cover
and i really want you to drop that in
the comments because
youtube told us for a given topic like
they want you to cover a specific topic
so a
let me know if you have a specific topic
and b
if you don't let me know how you're
being challenged
with this particular piece of
information because
sean can i still do a variety channel my
friend you can do whatever you want
like literally you know literally do
whatever you want
however if you want to follow our
playbook which is proven in works
then maybe consider submitting what you
want
to what works and following a system
which would be saying as frustrating as
it is or as limit
is limiting as it feels youtube is
telling us that
if i want search to work i need to be in
a
particular given topic a niche a
specific topic
to build my authority in that area and
then potentially consider pivoting your
plan
pivoting your channel pivoting your
niche but tell me
what topic do you cover and as a
reminder today's video is brought to you
by thinkmasterclass.com
everything we're talking about here is
coming straight from youtube as a source
right
but i'm not going to get into a ton of
strategies or a growth plan or our exact
exact system for how we generate
57 000 views per day as well as
how we turn those views into income in
multiple different ways
free class if you haven't watched it
it's new and updated for
2021 thinkmasterclass.com so don't miss
it and then of course
it's a free one-hour class at the end of
it i will tell you more about
what our program for youtube it's our
group coaching
and online course called video ranking
academy whether that's not right for you
or not
i want to encourage you implement this
information implement what you're
learning here
watch the free class implement what
you're learning there but if you
think man i want help i want to be
connected to a like-minded community of
purpose-driven
creators and entrepreneurs than um
that are crushing it on youtube and
really the
most vibrant and tactical and strategic
community
for youtube creators is our video
ranking academy community and private
facebook group
you can learn more about that at the end
of the free class free transparency so
you just know
the whole process but check it out
thinkmasterclass.com
and i know you'll get massive value out
of that as well
number four search and watch history
so youtube goes on in this article
that's not long
but gives us some very critical
information
in addition to those three main factors
which are the first three we covered we
strive to make search results
relevant for each user and we may
also consider your search and watch
history what does that mean that means
that your search results
are most likely different than my search
results and they could be influenced by
your search and watch history assuming
you're logged in or the viewers logged
in with a youtube account
and your search history is being tracked
which it is unless you turn that off
secondly even if you like turn it off it
actually is still being tracked most
likely because that's how youtube's
recommending you videos
thirdly even if you're not logged in
but you have cookies turned on and every
website now you go to website and it's
like
accept cookies so it pretty much like
forces it on you youtube is still
studying basically that ip address the
use of safari or google chrome or
whatever browser
that's again how you go to a raw youtube
account
deleted cookies or whatever and you
start from scratch what youtube doesn't
have any information i might just throw
you some videos from the trending page
as
soon as you start giving youtube
information
it'll start adjusting what you're seeing
in search
and recommended videos which is what
we're going to talk about in the next
part of this how youtube works series on
coffee with kannel
so youtube is taking into consideration
your previous behavior so let's read on
that's why your search results might
differ from another user search results
for the same query for example
if you were to watch a lot of sports
videos and search for cricut
we might recommend videos featuring the
sport cricket
rather than nature videos with crickets
in them
so you type in one word cricket and your
past history
is all kinds of sports and you know
in europe and your and all of a sudden
it's like oh
i assume you're wanting to watch cricket
the sport videos
versus you watch all kinds of nature
videos and like 4k nature drone footage
aren't those videos amazing
and it's like well this user likes
nature we're going to
show them videos of crickets in them so
these nuances have to do
with the fact that the viewer each
individual viewers
history is going to influence what is
being shown to them
so here's some big takeaways first of
all search results are different for
different viewers
the key then is to understand
the viewer that might be stated simply
but i can't underestimate how profound
it is when you begin to
understand the psychology
of the viewer that you want to reach
this is why defining who's your target
audience but even deeper
here on think marketing where we're
recording this during coffee with
cannell
we talk about defining like your
customer avatar or defining
kind of your ideal client to the degree
with which you understand
the the ideal viewer here's the thing
who else do they follow
like what are they thinking about what
are their favorite brands what are their
favorite podcasts what are their
favorite blogs
what books are they reading what movies
do they probably watch what tv shows do
they watch
what are their habits what are their
life patterns
what are their political beliefs what
are their and and a lot of what i threw
out there you know may or may not be
relevant but think about it
to the degree that you understand the
viewer
there's certain topics that might leap
off the page for them things that will
click
they want to click on more things that
will stand out to them more
if you were going to do an interview
show there's certain guests that they
would know
and that they would probably click on
and maybe some that they wouldn't know
that would maybe not do as well because
to the
to the degree of you understanding who
else they follow or what type of people
do they follow
or what kind of music are they into and
i'm getting very granular
but in general it's simply identifying
do you understand the viewer now chances
are
and to make this a little easier one of
the best things to do
is to create content for
yourself now don't get that wrong with
me saying don't create selfish content
what i mean
is to basically scratch your own itch
whereas you
usually are your avatar meaning
i would assume if you're connected here
on think marketing you also are into
personal development you're into
learning you're obviously on a learning
video right now
studying um you might know people
if you're watching this video you might
know who roberto blake is
you might know who catherine manning is
or vanessa lau is or tim schmoyer
or nick nimmin let me know if you who
are some of your favorite people that
you follow online tell me in the
comments
and i'll just see especially during the
live recording if i'm completely off
you might if you're into
entrepreneurship know who grant cardone
is or gary vaynerchuk is or marie forleo
um you might be into reading books or
reading audiobooks and maybe you've read
the book
think and grow rich or seven habits of
highly effective people
you as we get more personal probably
have
a core value if you're part of our core
community of family
of being purpose driven of of raising
kids of legacy
of impacting the next generation live
metal guy says tim schmoyer is amazing
and gary v is amazing
mama juice garyvee and vanessa lau so my
point
is as you begin to
understand what's happening in your
marketplace it also could be getting
ideas from the content that similar
creators are creating
it could be um even doing react videos
to other creators type of content
now you might get into say nerd culture
or
geek culture or comic book culture it
could do
it could have to do with like the
products you review understanding the
mcu the marvel uh
universe it could be understanding uh dc
versus marvel vs vertigo
like just to the degree with which
you're immersed
understanding the conversations the
topics the things that are happening in
your industry
that can very much influence your
strategy in the content that you create
etta says brenda burchard love him dean
graziosi tony robbins those guys
definitely
you know partner up we've got fire over
50 kathryn manning vanessa lau recent
growth video live speakers
even maybe how we pick our growth video
live speakers like are you seeing some
things
kyle krantz pat flynn income stream come
on my man pat absolutely amazing
so you start seeing some overlap here
but the key is in your niche
you just want to understand the viewer
and i don't want you to get any
like stuck in it around like it only has
to do with who else they follow i listed
a whole list
of these various things that could help
you understand how do i best
serve the viewer where are they in life
what are their problems
understanding your audience's problems
and ambitions
the to the greater greater degree that
you can do that to the
the greater degree of impact that you
will have now
i've got another powerful um tip for you
and then we're going to do some q a
but hit like if this has been pretty
valuable for you
but here's a quick story to illustrate
this so
i recently had a son his name shawn
bradley cannell
at the time of recording he is six weeks
old what a young legend
and uh so i've been spending a lot of
time in new dad life
changing diapers um shushing rocking the
baby trying to make him go to sleep and
taking him
at night and in the morning and uh so
when we're hanging out
um a lot of times after work you know
after i'm creating i work from home
and uh i will maybe hang out with my
wife and make some dinner a lot of times
we'll turn on youtube on our smart tv
and um on we use actually an apple tv so
i've got the apple remote
so here's what's interesting about
search is i actually youtube search
all night long but i do it with audio
and it basically i just press the little
microphone
siri opens up and i say um phil defranco
youtube
or i say uh running a marathon youtube
and here's some of the things i search
i've been searching for news studying
running
i've been studying the real estate
market i do a lot of personal finance
economy stuff health and nutrition
uh faith and leadership stuff there's
certain people i'll mention their name
and so two things are happening number
one youtube search is absolutely
happening
around a particular type of person me
that's
searching for content two it's building
up
this whole recommendations engine where
now i just go to home and i'll just look
at what youtube's recommending to me and
the more data it has on me like the
better
it serves content to me and that's the
conversation we're gonna have in part
two of this series
but let's just talk about running so i
will um
as i'm dictating these things and
running what is my psychology as a
runner
i'm somebody who's spending money on the
sport i'm in a place of
economic stability so i'm buying running
shoes i'm buying running gear i'm buying
running gels
so i'm watching like seth james i'm
discovering new creators
i'm wanting to know how do i run a
marathon uh which i haven't yet but i've
run two halves
in under like four and a half under four
i'm kind of thinking but four and a half
will probably be my target for the first
one
videos are being recommended to me and
then i'm also going down rabbit holes of
search
but the creators that are
there there's a lot of people earning
views from me in running
exercise avoid injury prevention best
shoes
um how to hit certain times biggest
mistakes
and so i'm it can lead to all kinds of
things affiliate marketing
with uh running shoes uh tank tops
shorts
linerless shorts you know like all of
the things and i'm just saying all of
that because
i am not just a creator i'm also a
viewer
you're not just a creator you're a
viewer how well
do you understand the viewer if you
really want to master youtube
search you need to discover your
audience's problems and ambitions
and really understand your viewer one of
the best ways to do that
is to think about your own behavior one
of the other best things to do
is to if all you're actually doing is
creating i know you should put your head
down and create
i also need you consuming um it's create
over consume
but if you want to understand youtube
you need to watch youtube
seems obvious but i'm often shocked
that some of the people who want to be
powerful creators on youtube
don't actually consume youtube here's i
think the key
this is not passive consumption like
binge watching
you know house of cards all the seasons
on netflix that's great too
this is active consumption through the
lens of study
to better understand your community your
niche how youtube works how the
recommended engine works
so i just want to encourage you that to
the degree with which you understand
your viewer and you can discover their
audience's problems and ambitions
at greater levels you will experience
more success
on youtube and if you want to learn more
about
uh this article and see from youtube
themselves what they've recommended
there's a link in the description down
below
and i want to encourage you coming up in
part two
we're going to be talking about youtube
recommendations and the algorithm
because this is really just the tip of
the iceberg
um but you're going to love that next
part so make sure you're subscribed
click the subscribe button click like
if you got value and um definitely check
out the free
master class if you have not watched
that yet at thinkmasterclass.com
to learn the tactics and the strategies
for really making youtube search
work for you and you'll learn my
framework for how you can get
views on youtube and build a real
business around your youtube influence
smash like if you got value out of this
video and
i will see you in the next one
coffee with kennel i'm still here uh
we're gonna probably cut up that first
training and paste it somewhere
else and so hey did you get value out of
that did you learn anything today
um and let me know your biggest
aha moment in the comments section below
um we are going to jump into some coffee
with kennel
and i'm excited because we have handmade
by
vashniya
it's actually handmade by vaishna hang
on hang on hang on hang on hang on hang
on
let me turn up the volume here all right
go for it
hi it's actually handmade by vaishna
that's that's
it's good to see you again this is your
third time on the show
yeah it's actually yeah it's the third
time i've been on the show
hey how are you doing not bad not bad
i am uh i'm actually a part-time
creator i try to balance school and
youtube so that's definitely one thing
that i've been working on i've also been
trying to
um create content that i can create in
the time that i'm
that's given to me but that also tries
to rank in search so that's also one
thing that's
definitely like something i'm trying to
work on
but yeah um
for me it's just how do i rank in search
with a with a niche that's
very oh yeah with a niche that's
pretty hard to rank in which is art
greeting cards i feel like everyone kind
of makes the same thing and some people
win some people don't yeah that's a
great question
and so when um
when you're
david fighting goliath you
need to have specific strategies
um and you need to lean on your
specific skills so it's interesting in
that biblical story
is that um david had the opportunity
to wear the king at the time saul's
armor
and used saul's weapons which did not
fit
and which he was not trained on and so
he
i think he put it on or he's like man
this doesn't even fit i'm gonna get
slaughtered if i go up
with against david if i go up against
goliath using the same old thing if you
will that everyone else
is doing so instead he did not wear that
armor he got five
smooth stones and he did what he knew
best which was
slingshotting a stone at a specific
place nailed goliath right in the
forehead won the war
and uh struck terror in um
the uh opposing force at that point
point in time by defeating their main
fighter
by by being a little unconventional so
you have to and i think there's there's
a book
by malcolm gladwell that is uh i would
highly recommend
i think it's called like goliath or
something you know like
um and let's look it up just because i
think it's worth
worth because it talks about how
companies malcolm
malcolm gladwell how companies
uh take down people that are
essentially bigger than them who would
have thought
it's titled david and goliath underdogs
misfits and the art of battling giants
so a lot of people watching and i'm sure
uh
can relate to your idea of feeling maybe
like these other channels or goliaths
and you're david
and so what i would recommend is trying
to cover
topics that other people are not
covering but you might say well they've
covered everything
i would i would challenge you that
that's not true i would think
a couple things specific product
reviews like okay what's some of the
products
that you use
for cards um well there's like specific
kind of like yes um so there's like
specific
like pens that i use that not many
people know unless you're in that niche
um like unibelt signo sakura jelly rolls
these are just
off the top of my uh my head um some
people use circuit um
makers but that's not like one thing
that i usually use
i really try to create on a budget so i
only have
a few things but yeah like pens like
there's like
like specific glues that people use like
tombow
mono multi glue i believe so those are
just like
okay so so just by looking at like
how to use a uniball pen uh fine liner
studying the competition but this is a
three-year-old video
um uniball air roller here these are all
kind of interesting testing different
pens
and this particular video got 7000 views
and here's here's when you look at
something specific like this it's kind
of niche maybe there's something there
but not only creating search-based
content but you can start showing up in
recommended content
when this is what i want you to see this
is that david strategy it's a specific
stone
shot to a specific place it's answering
specific questions
and it's going way more niche like we're
talking about a specific pen
how to use a specific pen um i've done
this over and over in tech it's how i've
built to where
i am today it's maybe covering a
specific camera or covering
two cameras versus each other or even
covering covering one niche
accessory and here's the key i'm not
suggesting
that this is like the only thing you
ever do ever
i'm suggesting that this is what you do
when you're trying to break through and
you get a couple videos where you're
like man i never thought my uniball pen
video would have got 5 000 views a year
and over the next couple years while
you're building up your channel
now that's led to 500 subscribers a year
and your 500 subscribers a year will
watch your day in my life at ucsc
video because it doesn't even matter as
much if that's like search based or not
but the reason they're like i was just
like looking for a uniball pen
i found you and now i kind of vibe with
you as well
so it just gives you a chance by having
a very specific
strategy for going after that particular
topic
that's the one strategy i would say the
second thing i would recommend is is
raise your consistency now i get it you
just said it
i'm trying to juggle school i'm
part-time
balancing school balancing youtube i
want to challenge you to get disciplined
i want to challenge you
to crank up your vision a little bit
this is not a guilt thing
as in like you're not doing enough i
know school has a lot of pressure i know
home
school has a lot of uh pressure i mean
uh homework
has a lot of pressure but it's about
priorities
and it's up to you you can put as much
energy into your youtube channel
as you want or not but there is
something powerful
about if you've got a vision for this
and you really want to make this happen
by choosing what events you say yes to
by choosing who you hang out to
with by choosing uh how you spend your
time
and by just like i'm sure
you make it a priority to study and
prepare
for the test that you know you have on
the calendar make sure that on your
calendar you make it a priority to get
your one video out a week
give yourself grace it's never guilt if
you miss it but
one of the huge keys to triggering
search triggering the youtube algorithm
getting enough videos that can help you
build the momentum so you can grow
to hit that tipping point this was the
key for me full-time job
balancing family balancing health
challenges in my family
balancing different setbacks and things
i was like man i need youtube to work
for me when i'm not working
so that someday i'll be able to jump out
and do this full time which is what
i did in the path to how i got here what
did that take
discipline focus sacrifice
i had to say no to some things now i can
say yes to whatever i want to
but i had to say no to maybe just
everybody hey sean you want to come hang
out i'm going to skip this time
because i know i got to shoot videos
tomorrow and i need to plan them tonight
on friday night
whatever it is if you want this to
really work i want to just challenge you
to get his discipline
and his focus with your time management
it's not hustle this
is not like in an unhealthy way it's not
burning yourself out
it's just choosing that when you are
awake
and what you're doing with your time is
very strategic
it's a key and i don't i'm not really
just sharing that with you i'm sure that
for everybody watching because everybody
whether it's school it might be kids it
might be three newborns and diapers
it might be working two jobs we all have
to get
really discipline with our time if we
want to have maximum impact
when our time is limited
okay thank you so much that wow
mind blown is that helpful yes for sure
hey i appreciate you so much and thank
you for being a part of uh
our community and coming on coffee with
cannell once again i think you're on
think marketing q a last time with
heather but uh it's awesome to see you
hanging out over here
thank you so much i appreciate you
smash like if you've been getting value
and uh
and let me know how's your time
management going
are you are you doing well with your
time scale from one to ten if you're
here live drop in the comments
10 you're crushing it you're you're you
have
your calendar scheduled on something
like google calendar
you're being disciplined with your time
you're avoiding time wasters you're
interrupting
interruptions you're saying no to lesser
tasks and things that don't matter as
much
uh that's a ten a one is like i'm pretty
much just going with the flow and
getting kicked around by my schedule
scale from one to ten how's your time
management ten is really good um
and one is not very good at all corey
says what do you think about two times a
week versus three times a week
um corey i think it's about quality
over quantity and only increasing the
quantity of videos
when you can keep the quality high corey
i would rather
make one great video this week that
is just like we discussed in this
training search based
great title great thumbnail and has the
potential
i know that the topic is actually being
searched for
i know that people are actually looking
for it and i know that if all goes well
people will watch it for weeks months
and years to come
i would rather spend more energy
creating a video like that than trying
to hit a target
of even two or three videos a week what
do i think
of the difference between two a week
versus three
three is better think media does five a
week
but think media also has multiple
creators nolan and omar and heather and
mel and
so you you're not comparing to the
amount of out
outputs and uploads you got to keep
quality high i would rather
if i was all the way back down to solo
creator uh
and didn't have tony and you know like
what think media has become
i would be really focusing on one a week
first
and i would only increase the volume
when i could get my systems by the way
when i'm part time one a week i think is
is actually the most practical i don't
know many people
if they're juggling multiple things when
i started to do
more than one a week it's once i started
i had already gone full time
and i started eventually i hired an
editor um even just part time i was
working with an intern
that just lived here in vegas and over
the summer and then i started paying
them then i started paying them more
and that was once i had already started
having money coming in from youtube ads
and affiliate marketing enough to scale
so that's why what we say here at think
media
and think marketing is one a week is
your goal
and not so much even to increase from
one a week
but to make sure that one a week is
great and you're doing all the other
things that we talk about and think mark
thinkmasterclass.com because what orbits
around the one a week are you answering
the comments are you making sure the
video is great are you researching well
is it a great thumbnail are you are you
going deep on it are you
if i'm also solo here's the exception
if i went back right now and i was had a
full-time job of 35 to 45 hours a week
and i wanted to build up my youtube side
hustle my schedule would probably be
one upload a week and one live stream a
week
i would probably try to upload a video
every tuesday and then i would go live
every saturday morning on a consistent
basis
with some type of show not unlike coffee
with cannel or something else relevant
could be short could be long
but quality over quantity cory is what i
would say
uh without question there um all right
bart lowe's barbecue what's up hey
hey man where you from what's your
channel about
and uh how can i help awesome hey uh so
good to be here uh my name is scott
and i'm bartlow's barbecue i'm in
oklahoma city
uh and my channel is all about teaching
people the basics of barbecue
uh do barbecue tips recipes reviews on
smokers
uh all sorts of stuff related to
barbecue
that's amazing and such a great example
you are already experiencing everything
we talked about in this training
youtube you already have channel
authority it's growing your
trustworthiness
on a particular topic your
authoritativeness and youtube is seeing
that
and we could see five uploads roughly
one a week
yep 184 new subscribers in the last
month and 13 000 views in the last month
really well done and it's awesome to see
the quality of what you're doing on your
channel uh what's your question today
well you know i one of the things that
i'm just realizing through
this community is what you were kind of
talking about niching down and
we were just kind of in the private chat
talking about this i discovered about a
month ago
just following a barbecue trend uh
within my community
uh put out a new accessory and i jump on
that trend so this is more of a
uh how do i leverage that uh video that
uh you know for my channel went really
well so i'm almost at 10 000 views on
that video within a month
uh and that was based on a trend that
was happening it's the uh
yeah there it is the 9200 uh
video yeah phenomenal so i'm trying to
figure out how to continue to leverage
uh that success um and for the longest
time when i first started youtube i was
just doing
recipes that i wanted to do and then
through your community realize i
my community likes more product reviews
more than just recipes so i kind of had
to switch gears to the past like 15 to
20 videos
you see a major switch um in
in the content related to barbecue so
that was kind of a cool aha moment so i
just want to keep on learning how to
leverage
uh those successful videos yeah it's
amazing and so
first of all you're doing really well
and as far as like some practical
uh tips is um
i think it's not either or in the case
of the content you're creating it's both
and
i think it's defining that there's
different types of videos
some videos should really be made to
attract
new audience meaning you jump on a trend
they don't know you
they know they're looking for the kamado
joe classic 2 slow roller
that brought in 9 200 new views i'm sure
it led to new subscribers as well
because it reached outside of your
audience it is okay though
and not only okay but important to also
create videos
that go deeper with people who are
already subscribed never forget that
once you've earned a subscriber
it still matters good title good
thumbnail because if the video falls
threat flat and your subscribers don't
click on it
then it won't even be shown to your
other subscribers but people have raised
their hand to say
all things barbecue show me the recipe
show me the thing and they're gonna
choose
so therefore some videos are for
strangers and some videos
are for subscribers and your goal is to
help a stranger
say man this guy's cool i want to
subscribe and be a deeper part of your
community
some videos also might eventually be
having people eventually
jump into like your free cookbook or buy
your
real cookbook or you know go to a
barbecue event that you want to do or
whatever and maybe that video falls
super flat it doesn't get 10 000 views
it gets 200 yeah but that's not the
point that the point was
hey we're doing a meetup and we're going
to be barbecuing together
the videos just have different purposes
yeah so the first thing i just want to
encourage you
is to give yourself permission
to not get too focused on constant
growth
but also to get essentially also focused
on the nurture
and to allow your creativity to be
expressed
still do the el pastor video still do
these other videos that you potentially
want to do
but add a balance of the videos that
will help your channel grow
and then the second tip how do you
leverage it is when you have a winner
you gotta make part two
whenever you have a winner on your
channel think about what part two is or
think about how you could spin it into a
series
for example you know think media existed
right when
the m50 came out the canon m50 which has
basically now become an iconic
camera um almost like the jordan ones
like uh shoe the m50 is known
it's searched it's liked now the mark ii
is out and everyone's frustrated
but for better or worse it's one of
those cameras that's just
iconic and so not only did we cover it
when it came out
but once it did really well and we saw
that it was doing well and we saw the
search volume and we saw the interest
and we saw that people love it
we've probably done 30 videos that have
been somewhat related to the m50 now
how to do photography with the m50 how
to shoot video with the m50 best
accessories for the m50 video test and
4k video test in slow motion for the m50
uh we haven't really done these but i
see other people do these
2019 is it still worth it to buy the m50
2020 is it still worth it to buy the amp
like you can keep talking about the
thing that
clearly is doing well in your channel
and here's a big key
your biggest video 9 200 views has
probably led
chances are close to or is the most is
the biggest trigger
of the most subscribers to your channel
yeah that's another
one right that's another good point they
probably want to see like okay
i watched it he said it's worth it i
bought it
so chances are it's been two weeks now
it's at their house
so now when you say like three cool ways
to use it
part two and and spin off videos that go
deeper on that topic that is doing well
um essentially to summarize the tip is
either how do you create a part two
that's great or how do you even create a
series a part two
three four five six based off certain
things
and so we continue to do both at think
media we do
a video that maybe also it's going to be
super helpful we want it to be in the
world we want it to add value
we want it to live on our youtube
channel so if somebody tweets me someday
i could say yeah we've answered it in
this video but it doesn't blow up it
never does super well it's an el pastor
video or some other niche video right
yep conversely when we see
these spikes these bright spots
of growth in certain videos we then go
our responses
let's double down like what's double
down look what is doubling down on this
look like what does it look like to talk
about this more
what does it look like to spin this one
video into 10
more over the next 10 months and that's
one of the best ways
to leverage a breakout video that's
awesome
uh follow-up question um is it wise to
utilize
similar title from that successful video
in
the next the series that i might do
absolutely but it doesn't need to also
be like is it worth it
the similar title in my case example
is canon m50 yeah that is the signal
seeing the camera in the thumbnail
seeing the title of the camera
in your case it's probably just kamado
joe
classic slow roller yep you know what i
mean
but is it worth it is not what it's
about this time it's like how to use it
or step by step
or something you know what i mean and so
so
let's land the plane with the tip look
at this
there an assembly video is interesting
you've already unboxed it which you've
maybe already crossed that one
but now it's telling us how to do pizza
in it that's one video now it's telling
us how to do a big green aid that's
another video
now it's saying the classic versus the
big joe so i'd be ordering up the big
joe
and i'd be doing that versus video and
and and with the views you've got
i would camp here like if i'm you this
is a this is a good synergy on this
coffee with kennel
i would do exactly what i just said like
this would be
my next four or five videos that we are
seeing be revealed here just by using
youtube search predictions and then
to that point uh brisket on the komodo
joe classic
etc to that point i like to batch
produce videos
so my way of releasing videos would
probably be
to buy that comparison thing to
get some food ingredients and to try to
shoot
all four to five videos i just
recommended on one saturday and just
smash them all
get them all batched and then release
those
over the next 10 weeks every other week
then the following saturday i would do
five other videos
about something uh else that alternates
between those
or or something else does that make
sense so
i would batch them but then i'd maybe
spread them out because then every week
they'd be like when did this become the
komodo joe channel like
it's like think media is not the m50
channel but whenever we release m50
videos they're peppered
throughout the release schedule that
would just be leveraging the strategy of
batch producing
to to cluster your activities and your
behaviors together
and even your purchasing and you're
reinvesting in the channel if you were
to buy the comparison smoker or by the
way
with the 10k views email the company be
like hey i want to do a comparison
between this and your thing
like here's a video i did and with 9200
views they're probably like oh yeah
we'll send you a review unit
so spending some time to work on that
and go deeper into this one thing
to keep um you know pulling the value
out of it the momentum out of it and
without
a doubt the interest here's the the
final i think important thing that ties
into this topic
yeah crazy thing is it's not even just
about subscribers
when it comes to the youtube algorithm
it's about consumption
so here's what i mean i think all of us
will relate to this once we watch
youtube for a while
as soon as you consume a video you don't
subscribe to the channel
you can i watch this like crazy uh these
two guys making music on beat
beat machines playing saxophones playing
drums
singing looping everything and my wife
and i and son were like this is amazing
we watched the whole nine minute thing
guess what started getting recommended
to us afterwards
that same video more music more videos
by the same artists
other popular videos so the fact that
this video has so much viewership on it
even if people didn't subscribe
when you upload another video about
kamado joe classic two
chances are that will be when you show
up on that person's home page
again is when you come
up with a similar topic a part two of
part three and so all that to say
this has been some super tactical stuff
for you that i think you could apply
and uh use to even grow your channel
faster thank you so much yeah that's so
awesome and it hits the topic today even
gaining authority um within my niche so
i appreciate the advice
my man hey thanks so much for coming on
coffee with kennel i appreciate you
appreciate you all right take care
all right my friends uh listen uh we
i've got some family stuff to do today
so i know a lot of people jumped on and
normally we sometimes go 90 minutes
two hours last time we went three and a
half hours but uh james jonathan jacob
marcus wendy diana ricky
uh in man slimmer let's hang out on a
future coffee with cannell if you're
just joining
watch the replay the first part was was
uh very tactical on youtube search
and um and i think you'll really enjoy
that
and then um smash like if you got value
out of the content today
i'll answer a quick question i see that
you have youtube premium is that
important
um it's not going to influence you as a
creator
except that i believe it will because if
you can afford it
time is important and when you have
youtube premium you do not have to watch
ads and i watch a lot of youtube
right and so uh by having youtube
premium
of course you also get access to their
originals which i think they just made
public
um but no you you don't need it for
creating content you may be like man i'm
counting every dollar right now
but uh time is money and it's nice to
save
uh time and so i would never not pay for
youtube premium
because i do not have ads and i also get
to listen
to just the audio i think on android you
could do this but i get to listen to
just the audio when i
shut down the youtube app dark screen
and i listen to a lot of
leadership i'm sure like you educational
marketing content
i started on youtube shut my phone down
and let the audio play
i believe on iphone and maybe even
android unless you kind of hack it
youtube premium lets you do that it also
lets you download your videos
so if you're gonna get on a plane you
can uh download the videos and then
watch them
uh and you're like no one's getting on
planes right now bro okay i get it but
anyways there's
uh youtube premium
will not help you rank your videos or
anything but it has a lot of benefits
and i
don't even hesitate to pay 10 bucks a
month or whatever it is for it smash
like if you got value today
coffee with canel our mission here at
think media is to help 10 000 people
create
a full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with online video
think masterclass.com and show notes in
the description down below
i am sean cannell and this is coffee
with kannel and i will see you
in the next video peace out